as NBC Bay Area columnist kind enough to
join us ray good morning how are you
hiya pops how you feeling oh I'm having
the time of somebody else's life how's
morale you think today with the Raiders
oh I think they're thrilled I think they
know that the refs screwed him last
night and that they can overcome this is
there a plan here
oh yeah it's to go into the toilet as
fast and as deeply as possible so that
they can start over and maybe be good in
three years
there's your plan so you shouldn't be
upset then with what you saw last night
if you know the plan well there therein
lies the complication because in two
years this game will be playing in
Nevada not Oakland so everybody who's
watching them now is profoundly offended
by the fact that they got sold yet one
more bill of goods before the team
leaves for good so I'm under normal
circumstances maybe you could get away
with it
but given the given these circumstances
people are hot because they were they
were told that Jon Gruden was going to
try to provide them a championship
before they left for Las Vegas I think
they can win a championship if you stand
on your head but that's about it
cuz they stink on stake see I forgot
about that that when he came in now did
Gruden say that he was going to deliver
a championship caliber team while he was
in Oakland or was that how he was sold
you know to the fan base coming back in
well I mean the thing is you know
everybody says stupid stuff at their
introductory press conference that's
sort of a given but and I think he meant
it on the day that he said it but I
think by April he had recalibrated his
thinking and when he decided to trade
khalil Mac he made it painfully clear
with what was going to happen here was
going to be the absolute antithesis of
championship football I don't think even
thought it could be this bad but he
positioned them so that it could be
yeah I and we've talked about this
before I think that was the game plan I
don't know if that was the game plan all
along its hey well I got a two-year
grace period and then this team is gonna
be my team when we get to Vegas you know
any remnants of Jack Del Rio is gonna be
gone by the time we get to Las Vegas the
question is how good are we when we get
to Vegas how much time do I have to get
them to a playoff caliber team and is
Derek Carr my quarterback how would you
answer those questions I don't know I
think I'd probably just break into a
despair cry if I was a Raider he's got
as many years as Mark Davis can what can
give them I mean you know I don't I
don't think anybody believes he's gonna
serve out all 10 years no but the way
the contract is structured there comes a
big payment if he's fired early so
that's one for two Derek Carr I mean any
day after June 2nd is a day when he's
got to worry about having to pack his
house because June 2nd is the day that
he can be released or traded and not
have the salary cap crush the Raiders
even more than it already has
as for the rest of it there's no way of
knowing because Gruden's history as a
coach is better than his history as a
general manager and if you're rebuilding
a team you're not doing it by drawing up
more arcane plays you're doing it by
bringing in different players and right
now they don't have a lot of players and
the players they do have know that
they're not gonna be around very long so
well I don't believe they walked into
last night's game not interested in
playing I think it's gone Don them
pretty early that effort would be wasted
so I think as the game went on they
decided to mail it in and boy good day
do you believe Gruden when he says that
he gets a lot of phone calls from people
that are dying to come play here I don't
believe when he said he's grood he came
to Auckland as the conquering hero he
was going to be you know mark Davis's
final gift to a fanbase he didn't want
to offend while taking the team out of
the town that they were in and instead
he has galvanized hatred locally by
being as tone-deaf as a guy can be and
so when he says that people are lining
up to play for the ravers I think the
only word that's wrong in that sentence
is for I think if you substituted it
with against I think he's on to
something
Thank You ray always great to catch up
always great to catch you in a great
mood every day here thank you Ray that's
a ray Ratto NBC Bay Area for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]